I like to joke immediately after sex
I've never believed there needs to be a
gentle gazing period afterwards I feel
like sex is done in its joke time it's
just a foolish time period after sex
like you just did these series of
ridiculous things together and now
you're just laying there men their
bodies were important 20 minutes ago you
had this powerful sexual man body and
now you're just sort of running those
flaccid post sex errands around the room
and just grabbing washcloths
there's no Dumber time in all of life
than the local errands that suddenly
need to be run just turns into this
naked fetching period and then you're
just wiping each other down like snow
off a car you just realized how foolish
everything is we just got married a
couple months ago and I mean thanks
thank you I don't know about weddings
I'm not like one of those waiting I
realize that's not a term but I just I
don't care about stuff like that like I
needed like a controlling [ __ ] in my
family they would just take over that
had strong opinions about flowers and my
mom my mom was like no help because
she's just too jazzy and liberal like
I'd call it my mom and I'm like mom what
do you do with like table settings and
she'd just be like celebrate diversity
and hang up the phone oh my god like the
day before the wedding she just texted
me strong women rock I'm like that's too
broad actually it's not helpful and then
we would go to these meetings and and
they would ask me questions I never knew
what I was supposed to say this woman
goes so what's your color story for your
day like that's a disgusting question
that's gross
I don't know what that means I'm like I
don't know do they have Jager and she
goes and she goes what colors make you
happy even that infuriates me like how
dumb do you have to be that you're
having a [ __ ] day and it just takes a
color to turn things around
what kind of wild [ __ ] it's just sad
until they see periwinkle blue that
didn't even work at like the olden days
like you know I was clinically depressed
Morris until I saw a flashing yellow on
that school bus and then I thought maybe
I won't stick the sock in the old
exhaust pipe tonight after all it takes
so much more than a color to make me
happy it takes like a specific cocktail
of like drugs and compliments to make me
feel good and my husband is like
worthless with compliments like on our
wedding day I'm walking down the aisle
and he's like bringing it I'm like
that's not simply won't suffice because
they did a good job with the makeup I'm
like you're not supposed to notice that
that's like saying I like the active ly
they plastered on your face for this
special occasion we should tip her big
for what she was able to do my goodness
and then she goes what do you want to do
for your first look pictures I didn't
know what that was but I guess before
the wedding they make the groom's sort
of stand in front of the bride and they
just turn her around and have him behold
her I'm so embarrassed for whoever came
up with that I mean he's already slept
with her several times it's not a reveal
I told him I was like when they turn me
around you should just be like this like
just look at me like a bad omen just
like me no Jewish please and he's a
fireman so now I'm a fire wife that's
actually not a term they've asked me
they asked me to stop saying that
the weird thing about firemen is they
actually love the fires I didn't know
that but they they don't like to miss a
fire so he comes down the road with me
and he has this app on his phone and
I'll just read me the fires he's missing
from the bed it's such a strange
experience he'll be like look at disp a
beautiful job that's a healthy fire
right there
I'll be like blood orange 1075 fire on
the third and fourth floor that's
probably light a 7-inch at 34 responding
right now I'm like I'm a person not a
walkie I don't know what you want me to
do with any of this information really
he's like now that feels fair I hear you
ten-four and on our wedding night I had
to pack a lot of specific outfits I feel
like a lot of guys get turned on by like
something they saw around the time of
their first wet dream they're always
trying to like recreate like like
something a teacher was wearing the very
first time their dick moved slightly you
know and I'm just kind of like let it go
like you're never gonna get back there
like every time you hook up he's like
can you just put on these corduroys lean
against this overhead projector and
collapse some erases together
he said I think I think I'd get hot if
you just clap him at the right pace like
this in the colleton it's like I'm
getting close it's just quick outfit
change if you don't mind could you just
stress like a school nurse and ask me
what I ate today please use the term
cold compress to put your hair at
Princess Leia buns oh [ __ ] I ejaculated
you don't need anything do ya I'm like
no I think I'm all I'm all set over in
my court I'll just change out of my
orthopedic nursing shoes circle back
with you in the living room he's like
God that sounds good tech for
[Applause]